yesterday was a pretty good start today
will be even better and David promised
us that tomorrow would be the best if
the past is any indication of at least
the immediate future David will deliver
we heard yesterday it's such a statement
it's a case of induction to reason from
experience means acquiring information
and detecting regularities so think
pigeons as art critics the
anthropologist I think it was Gregory
Bateson the anthropologist who said that
information is a difference that makes a
difference information starts that's
what he meant with being able to make a
distinction when there was none
unfortunately that is also how
hallucinations start so making a
distinction is therefore not enough it
has to be a distinction worth making but
therein lies the rub because it is not
anyone in particular who decides worth
in the longer run so in 1999 I spent a
year at the Institute for Advanced Study
in Princeton on a leave of absence from
the Santa Fe Institute and that is where
I first met David Cracow at that moment
I knew what it must have been for
explorers to first encounter a platypus
an egg-laying venomous duck-billed
beaver tailed auto footed mammal what
the seemingly paradoxical cross between
half a dozen species is to nationalists
David is to intellectuals David is an
intellectual platypus and that is an
endangered creature in a world chasing
the next tiny idea jointly record
is fundable by the NIH the NSF and your
peers luckily a zoo in Santa Fe known as
the scent of a Institute recognize the
treasure and captured the specimen that
zoo does not exist without our and your
support so if you consider it a worthy
cause and can make a donation please
consider doing so pitkin stein thinks of
genius is being talent exercised with
courage and the talent of david is
obvious in these lectures but it is
David's courage that permits him to tack
questions that hinge on integrating
disparate and the times perhaps
desperate domains of knowledge David's
perspective however has a precursor and
it goes under the name evolutionary
theory of cognition or more generally
evolutionary epistemology and one of the
major architects of evolutionary
epistemology was delayed ethologist
konrad lorenz who was honored in 1972
with the nobel prize for his work on
animal behavior with a yawn timber on
some wood perpendicular to count
lawrence thought that the world is
knowable but it is knowable through the
categories of the knower which were
shaped by evolution so evolutionary
adaptation by natural selection results
in a partial correspondence a kind of
isomorphism between the structure of the
world and the organization of the knower
on that account organisms do not make
theories of the world they are theories
of the world David cracow rightly
reminds us that this perspective needs
to be revisited and the time is ripe to
make it more rigorous quantitative and
formal let me quickly closed by quoting
Bates and again that information is a
difference that makes a difference
because there's not only aptly describes
our fast-paced time but it pretty much
summarizes four billion years of
evolution
that got us here cells acquired ever
more sophisticated molecular machinery
to refine old and make new distinctions
about their world cells learn to
distinguish between carbon dioxide and
glucose day and night self and non-self
but for all these molecular sensors to
make sense they must be followed up by
an information processing machinery that
determines actions and for these actions
to be worth making they must improve the
the vin yin bottom line of the actors
but there is more by virtue of their
actions observers change the very world
they observe does giving rise to
potentially new differences that might
become worth detecting it is this
feedback to turns evolution into both an
information gathering and creating
process an information race that gave
rise to vast molecular and cellular
networks cellular interaction networks
in fact the Internet's before the
internet and David second lecture will
illuminate this process David
haha alright here's the platypus the
notice and machines were on my side the
interference were has been too swamped
his comments I should say you know when
Walter was being made a professor at
Harvard one of his letter writers said
do not hire water would be like not
hiring vipin Steen and so you perhaps
you'd get that not me okay so good so as
well just said tonight will be a sort of
interlude between an exciting first talk
and a truly exciting verge so let's just
start with some action again I'll use
that you know little warning icon when
the goings get tough
right that's Prokofiev the dance for the
night and that's a real tool using
octopus learned to do that over its
lifetime they use coconuts the way that
we would use a shield and I put that up
at the beginning just to remind you of
where I stand and that is that I believe
that cognition and intelligence is
ubiquitous its present across nature and
multiple scales within ourselves and
today will be really emphasizing that
multiscale cognition within the organism
but I need to introduce you to how we've
thought about the evolution of
intelligence in the past yesterday I
started with some crazy anthropological
theories and I will now show you the
current state of the art in science that
tries to account for how it is that we
use iPads right how it is that we use
language as we do what is it right that
you could extract from the basic anatomy
or genetics that might be a clue to what
we think as exceptional human
characteristics and so the obvious thing
is that we have such huge brains it
doesn't take a scientist to recognize
that Albert Einstein's brain is
significantly larger than the brain of
the mouse lemur and whereas Albert
Einstein introduced us to curved
space-time the Lemur eats grapes in a
forest and and here the the two brains
drawn to relative correct scale and and
so for many years that was considered
the critical if you like anatomical
correlative our exceptional capability
just larger brains and it's not totally
stupid because larger brains correlate
with a larger number of nerve cells
brain cells and so if you go from very
tiny little brains down there to to that
huge human brain over there down here
what you have is a number representing
the number of neurons and so it's not
just a naive assumption that the larger
brain is associated with greater
intelligent there is in fact some if you
like mechanistic justification if you
believe that the cells and
brain contribute to the brains abilities
oops if you just look at the size of
brains in nature unfortunately don't
have the largest neither do we have the
largest number of cells in our brains
and so it can't just be that because if
you're trying to account for traits that
you think of as uniquely human I mean
for all we know the toothed whale does
all sorts of things that we don't
appreciate but we're trying to account
for culture symbolic language music
mathematics and so forth so that doesn't
seem to work too well that might be
naive and so an alternative approach is
to consider what's called the
uncivilized ation quotient that's the
ratio of the brain to body size so for
example you might expect a whale to have
a larger brain because asked after all
it has a larger body and so if you look
here his body size body weight against
brain weight and there's a trend this is
called a scaling law you've probably
seen too many of these going to Santa Fe
Institute talks but you'll see that
there are points that lie on the line
and then there are points that buck the
trend so the batch for its body size in
fact has a smaller brain weight than you
might expect so based on this kind of
reasoning you'd think the bat wasn't
very intelligent okay and as you go up
here if you look at the blue whale
that's rather like the batch even though
it has a huge brain it's below that line
and so it's lower than you might expect
given the trend and so you look at
humans you say this is fantastic look at
humans not only do they have big brains
but they're way above the line oops so
is the dusky dolphin so that doesn't
seem to work too well either so people
have looked much more carefully at
scaling within the brain not just the
brain to the body but parts of the brain
that we know are associated with what we
might call higher cognitive processes
and parts of the brain that are not
implicated in those kinds of processes
so for example looking at sure you can
see this at the back and the prefrontal
cortex that is associated with strategy
a decision making and the neocortex
which also is involved in higher
functions but not quite as high if you
like
is the prefrontal cortex and what we
have here is the neocortex area against
the absolute prefrontal cortex area or
the relative and here when you look at
the primates notice no whales on these
plots the humans do come out rather well
so in terms of relative brain regions
there does seem to be some evidence that
humans are different at least from the
other primates now people now have also
of course looked at genetics so genes
associated with difference and so how
does this work what we do is this is a
tree what we call an evolutionary tree
and we're looking 20 million years back
now if you look at the rodents the rat
and the mouse their common ancestors 20
million years ago and yet their brains
remain more or less identical this is
actually the ratio of the ratio of the
brain size to body size the ratio of the
in careful ization quotients doesn't
matter whereas if you look here up at
the primates in the same time 20 million
years there's been a significant
divergence of our brain from the macaque
brain and over here what this is is it
gives you if you like the rate of
evolutionary change if you look at
housekeeping genes genes that are
present in all cells there's no
difference between the rodents and the
primates but if you look at genes that
are expressed in brain tissue it looks
as if the rate of change is accelerated
in the primates compared to the rodents
okay but note that this is true for all
the primates not just us in relation to
the other primates this is the most
recent result and in fact one of the
authors on this paper is Michael lachman
who was a former postdoc the Santa Fe
Institute who now works in Leipzig and
this is quite complicated this picture
but what you have here is you have many
many many genes and you're looking at
their rates of expression and when it's
read that gene is more highly expressed
in a human and when it's blue it's more
highly expressed in a chimp and you have
different tissues so this would be this
this column of the brain tissue heart
tissue kidney tissue liver and testes
and you can probably already see
that if you look at the differences
across tissues the only tissue that
shows a significant change in expression
are the testicles okay so which is a
little bit alarming because we really
really wanted the lot of the highest
part to be over there at brain so what
I'm telling you is based on this
evolutionary evidence at least over a
period of about 80 million years there
doesn't seem to be a very significant
difference that we can where we can that
we can use if you like to explain
differences in cognitive function and
yet
what a piece of work is a man noble in
reason how infinite in faculties in form
and moving how Express and admirable
inflation how like an angel in
apprehension how like a god the beauty
of the world the paragon of animals yet
to me what is this quintessence of dust
delights not me right but you can't help
being to be delighted by that I
Shakespeare writer I mean there's
something that we have to account for
him and so I want to broaden the
evolutionary question go further back in
time further than the 18 million years
right back to the formation of our
galaxy so you know our solar system is
about you know form fairly quickly after
the big bangs I don't know at 13.5
billion years or so and the earth are
accretive out of the solar nebula about
4.6 billion years ago and then within
eight hundred million years a relatively
short period of time life appeared on
the earth a simple form of life like
bacteria it took you can't sit in this
slide about two billion years for those
cells to form the cells to evolve into
the cells that we're made from
eukaryotic cells these are called
prokaryotic cells and then another 800
million years to get jellyfish but the
wonderful thing to realize is that once
you had jellyfish jellyfish you had
Darwin you had Isaac Newton you had
murray gell-mann right it the the long
delay in the evolution on earth wasn't
in the formation of things we view is
uniquely complicated but in fact the
evolution of a cell and so what I'm
going to be talking about today is the
extraordinary power of the cell a little
bit along the lines that Walter
mentioned because if we understand that
I think will understand intelligence
here's another way of saying it this is
just a spiral representation of history
with time unfolding up as we move up
through the spiral they were you see the
4.6 billion years of Earth history and
the longest delay that I mentioned in
going from these bacterial cells to
eukaryotic cells cells with a nucleus
with an internal membrane and
chromosomes that segregate independently
so let's talk about cellular
intelligence and you already know what I
mean I mean representation I mean
inference I mean strategy and I mean
competition I mean the possession of
those basic ingredients of intelligence
I do not mean high IQ test and so here's
what you might think of a set of a
sensory system mediated by a nervous
system so here's someone eating what I
assume it could be a cigar it's more
likely that it's a sausage but and you
know that they're looking at it and
they're smelling it and they're tasting
it and that's being processed by a whole
range of specialized cell types but a
cell has a similar structure on its
surface it has receptors it has pathways
that act a little bit like sensory
pathways in the nervous system and these
will get integrated into the nucleus
that looks a little bit like on your
cortex so there's a structure to the
cell that resembles at least
superficially the structure of the
nervous system and oops I'm sorry in
1965 these two gentlemen's a Minoan
shaqab were working on the if you like
the internal circuitry of e.coli a
bacterium and this is the origin of this
field that you might have heard of
called gene regulation that is the
internal circuits that turn one gene on
and turn another gene off according to
inputs from the environment okay and
these circuits need to quite
extraordinarily complex behavior at the
level of single cells I'm going to show
you a video and what you're going to see
is you're going to see a eukaryotic cell
a white blood cell chasing a bacterium
surrounded by red blood cells oops
that's the bathroom
okay triumph of the eukaryote all right
and so it was caught now if I showed you
that video you said well that's an
animal I can't quite see it looks a bit
pixelated but it's one animal pursuing
another animal in some complicated
environment and because of course it had
to sense where it was had to pursue it
had to finally apprehend it and consume
it and the e.coli was evading it and so
on right so it looks like a form of
intelligence it requires strategy
requires representation and inference
but there are no nerve cells here these
are single cells so each of these cells
has in them along the lines I said
complicated molecular nervous system at
a lower level that does has nothing to
do with no cells so I'm going to spend
most of my time talking about cells in
tissues the capabilities of cells in in
aggregate not on their own and that
leads to all sorts of complexities that
you will probably start to think about
but what I want to show you is that when
you probe the capability of the
single-cell you observe extraordinary
representational power and so again just
for those of you who weren't here yes
your those who were I want to make this
contrast between what i call the dumb
sell the done cells a bit like an
integrated circuit or transistor doesn't
really do anything as opposed to the
intelligence cell these are real cells
by the way these are nerve cells during
the development of your brain trying to
find partners and they're moving around
and they're probing axons to determine
whether they like them or not and if
they like them they'll envelop them
otherwise they'll leave them alone and
so these are housed real cells in your
body in your brain behave they don't
have anything like that in other words
they don't look like our idealized
computational model of the brain which
is wrong so I'm just gonna give you an
example of what a cell can do this comes
from some of my own work and I call it
cellular perfect pitch and for those of
you don't know what perfect pictures and
let me show you how about this no
II that's right how about this note hit
it you are a sight that's a flat 3 all
right now you think wow wow that kid
well one cell can do that right and and
so this is what happens when you you you
you estimate your guests a note sound is
transmitted as an oscillation in air at
a certain frequency higher notes
oscillate faster than lower notes and
when you hear them your brain processes
that periodic signal and you conclude
that is a certain frequency that we
associate with a symbol like C or a
b-flat and cells do exactly the same
thing the difference is instead of it
being a sound wave it's a wave of
concentration of a protein released by
the brain and if it's a low frequency
wave the cells turn on one gene through
a complicated circuit that we've worked
out mathematically and if it's
propagated in a wave at high frequency
it turns on another one and the reason
this matters is because these little
cells that we have in our brains men and
women they actually mediate the entire
reproductive cycle which occurs at much
lower frequencies in mammals in female
mammals typically on the order of a
month so all of that complicated
reproductive periodicity is mediated by
a little selling your brain that has
perfect pitch and if it gets it wrong
all of that gets messed up now it would
be inappropriate to talk about the power
of cells if I didn't mention the two
most famous cells in neuroscience and
these would be if you like face cells
face-selective cells and mirror neurons
I'm sure some of you have heard about
face sales have an interesting history
in the 1970s scientists called gross was
probing neurons in monkey brains and he
found cells that responded exclusively
to images of hands he gave them various
things that look like hands
feet various pads and they didn't
respond but the only responded two hands
so he called them hand sells people for
there's no way that you have a cell in
your brain that responds only to a hand
and that led to a hypothesis they called
the grandmother neuron that the in fat
if that's true then you might have a
cell in your brain that exclusively
respond to the image of your granny and
that was considered funny and it was a
bit of joke until they discovered it was
true so I'm going to talk about these
two different kinds of cell apologies to
class square as the the road could be
finess has been rained and I I did this
for a reason because the cells i'll talk
about mirror neurons not only do they
recognize expressions that they are
actually the roots to empathy to
self-knowledge so this is what it means
to be face-selective and so this is
recording for I'm not sure how well you
can see at the back this is recording
from a single cell and these are you
can't see the monkey faces where slight
modifications have been made so hear a
band has been removed here you've put a
human face in you hear you freeze it
with the hand here you've rotated the
head and what you observe is this what
this little histogram represents is the
strength of response of firing of a
nerve cell and what you see here is it
responds most strongly to this image and
this image enter the partially occluded
images or the rotated profiles it
responds less strongly in his brush that
would be call the control and up here is
a much stronger response a profile
selective cell that only responds to
cells in profile so this is quite
remarkable right of course these cells
exist in the context of many other cells
that are giving them information that at
some level this cell is representing an
object a single cell as complex as a
face now what happens when you remove
those cells in humans for example when
humans suffer a stroke in this test
Terry takes a Polaroid picture of her
mother
ter you just took a picture of your
mother yeah I want you to take a look at
these and see if any of them are the
picture you took or not see me now
Massachusetts General Hospital
researcher dr. Nancy ed cough shows
Terry several Polaroids with only faces
showing and asks Terry to pick out her
mother you know if you had to guess
which looks you the most like you love
him just looking now you can't tell
which one of these men these really look
like your monger too you know ok if you
just come up the basement I just look at
the clothes I could can't you want me to
end ever done ok why don't I do that
I'll uncover them so you can see what
they're wearing and other parts the
picture you see that's her cuz assured
written language so i don't know if you
heard that it's bit muffled but she was
unable to identify her mother from her
mother's face but when they revealed the
clothing that she was wearing in a
characteristic pink jersey then she was
able to identify so she wasn't in any
way visually impaired she could explain
to you what the components of a scene
were but she just couldn't get the face
ok and that's the inferential power of a
single population of cells now okay not
good wrong oops back in this test let me
show you in another video so these are
two neonates newly born primates one huh
managed and one monkey and there they've
never seen themselves obviously and
they're being exposed to faces this one
across species and notice what they're
doing they're actually imitating what
they're seeing
now let me ask you which is cuter that
one
alright they went out on the cuteness
dimension to know I'm sure to the
parents the baby is totally adorable now
what's remarkable about these kinds of
capabilities is that they also are
computed by single cells called mirror
neurons okay mirror neurons have been
discovered very recently I'm sure
there's a Nobel Prize about to be given
out for them and what mirror neurons do
is something very interesting mirror
neurons are light up when they see you
do something like move your hand right
but they also light up oh let me just
get that right if I move my hand
Walter's mirror neuron would light up
but if he moved his hand the same neuron
would light up that's what defines it as
a mirror neuron the sense that both
responds to an image in someone else
when someone else moves and also it
responds to your own motion in the same
domain so they're both sensory and motor
does that make sense to you and this is
considered the root of empathy so when
you cry because jr. died an episode of
Dallas I think right or you cry because
you see someone's eye watering you think
oh my god am I really that sentimental
no you just have a very active mirror
neuron okay because your mirror neuron
is generating the response that's
identical to the image in your brain
single cells and so here's the kinds of
experiments people do they'll show you
images like this have an actress and
she's asked to pull faces and you were
asked as the experimental subjects to
classify them in a multiple choice test
according to their magnitude so here
you'd be shown a movie with her pulling
that facing well is that happy but I
don't think so is it fear yes yes not
sad not and so forth and people are
quite consistent in how they label
expressions and here's another one
what's that I don't know and so unhappy
that's obvious discussed it's an
interesting complicated one people still
get it quite right it's put a lot of
variance in response but they don't
typically confuse them and the
interesting point is that each of these
images is in fact encoded represented in
a different population of mirror
neurons and so what you do is you put
people in brain scanners and you ask
them to do one of two things to look at
the movie and you measure their brain or
to copy the facial expression so that's
viewing in white because I'm sure you
can't read out the back versus imitating
in black right so these cells if you
imitate they fire more actively but the
same cells will fire just by looking
okay but you'll see what's quite
interesting here is the magnitude of
response is proportional to the
intensity of the emotion so here you get
a very strong fear response right so if
you look at something frightening or you
make a frightening face those cells
really fine but different mirror neurons
have different profiles right so this is
in the temple court in the temporal
cortex this in the somatosensory cortex
and hear things are quite different
these mirror neurons respond most
actively to neutral right and this is
the amygdala which is very strongly
emotionally implicated and that actually
responds quite strong to neutral and too
happy so you have different populations
in your brain which are encoding
responses to emotional or affective
states in people you look at and pathak
Lee so single cells so I just want to
make this point clear these cells exist
in a complicated circuit of cells okay
but it could be the case that the way
the brain works is that no single cell
ever represents the whole it could be if
you look at the Mona Lisa that's been
pixelated for an image on Times Square
that every cell just encodes one of
these colored rectangles it never ever
does the integration where a single cell
represents the whole which they do
computers don't have this characteristic
if you look at a single transistor
integrated circuit it only ever
represents a part of the whole your
brain has a very intriguing
characteristic that there are soul there
are cells that represent the whole the
entirety now there are limits to cells
and so why do we ever shift from being
single celled prokaryotes
to being you carrots what are the
driving forces in getting cells to
aggregate now to answer this question we
look at organisms that have both
features in their single life cycle this
is known as a slime mold no and most of
the time it lives as a single-celled
creature but when the environment
becomes bad when it dries up they
aggregate and form a multicellular
organism and that multicellular organism
can migrate and when it's migrated to a
new area where there's food available it
stops some cells form the foot and
they're destined to die and some form
the fruiting body which will regenerate
the next population of slime molds so
there's a clue here that in some sense
the reason why you move into this
multicellular configuration is to
explore a space of solutions that you
couldn't as a single cell and I guess
back to yesterday what I was talking
about in terms of intelligence as being
fundamentally about search so here's a
video from John Boehner it's an old
colleague of mine from Princeton who's
one of the pioneers in this area and
it's just going to show you that life
cycle their extraordinary the way it
works in fact is this center here is
sending out pulses of a chemical called
cyclic anp and they respond to it by
tracking towards it and that's the
aggregation signal and once we've
aggregated they move into this phase
which you're going to see now and so
this thing is made of many many cells
only these will get to reproduce and all
of these will die it's in fact you took
that footage I think in the 50s it's
still the best footage of the slime mold
sporulation for those of us who are
physio Nardo's of this cinematic art
okay this is another slime mold this is
its lifecycle slightly different this
one's kind of smart and so this one all
the cells come together they form one
giant cell called a Polly nucleated cell
and then it sends out channels looking
for food and when it finds food those
channels get stabilized and the channels
that don't find food dye okay and so
you're going to see that now so these
are actually little maze grains here's a
mold and you'll see what I just
described
you
so what one really enterprising
researcher did is he took these maize
grains and he distributed them according
to the major train stations in Japan in
Tokyo and he said how would it design
the railway system right and what you
see actually this is a solution to quite
a hard optimization problem finding the
shortest path between all of these stops
and it came up with a solution this is
the mold Network not to scale but it
came up with a solution that's in fact
as good in terms of the distance
traveled as that came that was designed
by the engineers the architects of the
rail system so this is kind of
remarkable that stupid little mold we
should use them in little silicon
testitude to do experiments you
architecture to design our highways
they'll do a hell of a lot better than
our government so this is a clue to why
you go multi-cell it gives you this
greater inferential power because what
you can do is if you head off in a
direction that's not profitable you'll
die off right but if you go in a
direction that works you'll stabilize it
so there's that sort of Darwinian flavor
again this exploratory flavor where you
do inference by having things die back
now I put this in for you this is a
little art interlude and what you'll see
is amazed with a slime mold and then
you'll see a human imitating it
you
hmm
I love it I've transfix slime mold off
all right okay so you know the same
illness we put here judge not at all
convincing of the slime mold so all
right so what do I told you I tried to
give you a sense of how impressive
individual cells are there
representational power and and I
mentioned the slime molds really to make
the point that your brain is really that
your brain is really lots of those slime
molds that are behaving not that
differently right aggregated and under
slightly different rules of control and
that's what's generating what we
consider intelligence and i'm going to
show you one of the remarkable
capabilities of our species and others
to a lesser degree when you aggregate
cells and that's our ability to count
now in every conversation I've ever had
about human intelligence people will say
well it's obvious what makes us special
its language because no other species
control right and I have problems with
that not just with a problem with the
question of whether other species can
communicate or not symbolically but the
fact it seems to me having a number
sense is more important so if you are
you know an organism that goes to war
that battles with other troops your
monkey and you don't count correctly the
number of opponents you're facing you
will die there's no need for
communication you just need to back out
if you realize that you're outnumbered
so there is a symbolic internal
cognitive manipulation which seems to me
more important the sin but then the
symbolic communication are required by
language I'm not deprecating language
I'm just saying that I don't think
mathematics six on language I think
language might sit on mathematics so let
me show how it works and this is one of
those moments where you get your warning
so out with a text messaging or
attention okay here are two are monkeys
rosencrantz and Macduff their real names
and your I think I know why they were
cool there I wasn't sure so and what you
did is the following if you remember
yesterday I showed you that video of the
chimps identifying numbers and getting
them in the right order
and so you give them objects in various
different colors and different
geometries what they have to do on it on
a video screen is identify either the
larger set or the smaller set right so
you might press the larger one first and
then the smaller one right so that's
auden ality just numbers is called
numerosity and what you do is you train
them to be able to get the relative
magnitude of those sets correct over and
over and over again and so here's what
happens you start & training this is 125
because how many times do they get it
right you can see that rose and crown
starts out off ahead and I think this is
why he might be called Macduff when it
comes to the end Macduff is right there
up with him is remember like Duff did
rather well at the end of one of
Shakespeare's plays and so maybe that's
why they called him Macduff and what you
then do is you test them out of sample
you test them with numbers that they've
never seen before and they are
consistently way above chance in their
accuracy these are not chimps right
these are monkeys so that's quite
remarkable and how is it done okay to
understand that need to show you another
experiment and this is how it works a
monkey's asked to look at a point on a
screen you then give it a set of points
okay 500 milliseconds you then remove
the points and shit that show at the
point on the screen again and then you
show it two sets and you ask which one
has the same number of points as the
original now you get to look at it for
500 milliseconds it's not easy even for
us as you'll see we don't do any better
okay does everyone understand and this
is what happens and so this is a plot
and it says this is the number of points
that you saw at first and this is your
accuracy so look over here you see this
very broad shouldered curve what they
saw was 24 but they couldn't recall
perfectly accurately whether it was 24
that often say 16 or those so 34 but
when they see two they always get it
more as exactly right okay and this is
just the logarithm of that plot for
those who care the very well known
result called Weber's law exponential
scale
in biophysics but look at humans
identical ok so again we haven't really
I identical it's actually a remarkable
result we do really well when we get
those initial points projector to us
were there a few of them and we do very
badly when there are many and we do no
better than a monkey so what's going on
here what I'm telling you is from the
brains point of view you're no better at
representing money numbers that are
monkey I said money which is some kind
of Freudian slip when it can when it
came to numbers all right and how has it
done so what you're looking at here is
you're looking at individual cells and
this is the number of objects and this
is their firing rate how often they turn
on what you see is it here's a cell that
responds to 18 here's a cell that
responds to 24 here's a cell that
responds to 30 maximally okay this is
called a labeled line code what happens
is in our brains in the intraparietal
sulcus and in monkey brains we have
cells that represent number okay this is
what this is so when you see a set of
objects a cell will light up in your
brain that says 16 so surprising so that
I think this raises a significant puzzle
if monkey brains can do this as well as
us right or we do as badly as them how
is it that we're able to represent
numbers like a googolplex right how can
we multiply large primes what's going on
and I think this is the key to what
makes human beings special so here's the
puzzle okay I'm telling you that when
you see numbers and this is this
Babylonian and mine again go get
projected back into the brain or a human
or a monkey and it gets encoded in the
brain as a certain value right oh and if
that's true why aren't monkeys as good
as we are doing mathematics because it
all gets turned into the same brain code
right so why do we do it better and
here's why I think we do it better so
here's some number that we see a number
of
people it gets projected back finally
reaching this intraparietal area sulcus
in the brain what then happens in us is
it gets abstract and it gets sent
forward to the prefrontal cortex and
there are experiments but I thought they
were a little bit technical so you'd
want to show you which show how that
happens that gets turned into a motor
schema gets shunted to the motor cortex
which then writes it out in the form of
sayre glyph back lift then goes back
into the eyes and that gets projected to
a new part of the brain called the
visual area so something very
interesting has happened here some
number has been coded in these very
simple cells that we have and monkeys
have but then we do something rather
interesting we actually externalize it
in a simple system and reprojection new
part of the brain that's different from
the part of the brain that the number
was first projected to okay now the
question is why do we have to do this
why can't we just do that okay this is
the great mystery what I'm going to tell
you is what makes us clever is our
ability to shunt representations from
one cell population to another so as to
make a problem effortless so this is the
human future without culture we'd be
nothing right if I just put you in the
wild you wouldn't out-compete a monkey
right the reason why we all seem so
smart is because tons and tons of people
over the history of our species have
been shunting things into our
environment this is the repository of
knowledge that we draw on not this and
unfortunately other species don't seem
to have that capability to externalize
outsource representation so this is what
we do okay this is very special right
and this is what makes us smart now
there's another feature of outsourcing
representations which needs to be noted
and that is its collab
I alluded to that just now the fact is
that if I have an idea in my head you
don't have access to it if I make a
mistake you can't correct it but if I go
to a blackboard one of my colleagues is
nicer to me that's wrong you made an you
made a mistake they can error correct
okay that's not something you can do in
your head so this externalization of
representations allows for collective
cognition so no but not always as i'm
going to show you an instance where it
can go horribly wrong look here i'll
show you when we run this out here and
now 25 / 5 is fine you see you the fight
won't go to 2 will it no but five goes
into 25 5 times you see you're wrong
belly now I'm pretty good mathematician
now 5 into 25 5 won't go into too no but
five goes into 51 now we didn't use the
tube before so we're bring it down here
I've into 20 goes for turnips there you
are 5 in 225 40 oh right well okay
that's the virtue of externalizing your
cognition I meet many people who make
remarks that are no more sensible than
that but you can't really gauge whether
or not they're making a mistake until
you ask them to stand up at the board
that's why scientists are so ruthless in
asking people to expose their thinking
processes publicly as I'm doing now now
you could say where did this come from
where are the seeds of this capability
and it's interesting i was talking to
marry Charlotte on her radio show she
was quite right she pointed out that
there is an analogy in nature and that's
what we call niche construction that
there are other animals that do
externalize internal cognitive states
and collaboratively operate on them okay
now this is a new era in fact a number
of us at the Institute Jessica flack
here Doug earlier and I have worked a
lot on
this theory but we're nowhere near
understanding how the creation of these
kinds of animal architectures leads into
the creation of external symbol systems
and that's an interesting open territory
to explore the point is that for humans
we've created infinite working memory
right we've created the capability
through culture through external
artifacts of in fact creating a
repository resource that's absolutely
endless and that's I think the key to
our are true intelligence this is a
photograph of Trinity College Library so
as I said the other day that's easy for
a human and monkey we now know that
monkeys can go to 30 so can we we can't
do much better but that's easy for a
human it's hard for a monkey because it
can't do that can't write down Arabic
numerals base 10 okay so it's not
greater numerical competence we don't
have greater numerical competence we
have greater representational competence
right and we have greater
representational competence in the
external environment ok so it's anchored
and moreover anchored in geometry and
i'm going to give you an example of how
this works now oh yes Stan ullam
intruded this before his ex as I read
his autobiography and this what you said
it is possible that human thought codes
but what's the human thought codes
encodes we'd say I guess things not in
terms of words for most people think
pictorially not verbally there is a way
of writing abstract thought in a kind of
shorthand one may call this a visual
algorithm see I think that's really what
we're doing we might be doing language
too but I think we're doing this first
okay and we in fact do this when we
build tools when animals build tools
they're encoding solutions to problems
in in some sense in physical algorithms
okay so here's a beautiful example of
this so I'm going to just recap quickly
because we're getting to the end of this
this tonight's talk what I'm telling you
is what the brain does is it shifts from
an area where it has to think hard about
a problem to an area where a bit of
dedicated Rangers you can solve the
problem without thought
okay so think about learning a sport
when you first learn how to wield a
tennis racket you have to think really
hard about it you keep messing up and in
time it seems to become automatic and we
have a colloquial term we use equip
muscle memory there's no memory your
muscles right its neural it's encoding
your brain but it's being shunted to a
different part of your cortex which is
much more efficient at representing
trajectories in space and what I'm going
to tell you is smart people are actually
less smart than you think because what
they're doing is they're taking a
problem that you have to think hard
about and they're re representing it so
that for them it becomes trivial so in
fact they're more stupid right that you
know it's the key to intelligence is
efficiently wielding neural tissue right
so when you use a computer graphics chip
to do very fast calculations you realize
that the way of writing code to more
efficiently solve problems instead of
having to use a regular processor
intelligence is fundamentally about
stupidity it's kind of peculiar so
here's an example of that so here's an
abacus everyone knows when abacuses this
these are called the god beads if you
like musical the earth beads these are
worth unit 5 units these are worth
single units and so in the up position
here you get one and this remains in the
neutral position and for you move for up
seven you move that one down to give you
five two up to give you seven if you
will use an abacus and you can represent
numbers and add in very simple ways by
just manipulating the beavs the upper
and lower beads and there are master
abacus users okay and here's an
experiment it's a little bit like that
monkey experiment I mentioned before I
show two groups of people a large number
I show them to master abacus users right
and I show them to people who are
competent arithmetic Lee okay and then I
put it lay in and then I ask you is that
the same number as you saw before okay
and that's it that's the experiment
recall of a large number
and you take these people and you put
them in a brain scanner and you see
something very intriguing I think that
everyone in this room who hasn't been
trained intensively in the art of the
abacus the way you represent large
numbers is just by remembering the
symbols you say four seven three one
four seven three ones okay that's not
how an abacus master remembers it so
what happens to us is so look we have
different brain regions here Green for
the abacus experts red for the rest of
us okay so here's a big red area that
lights up okay and that's the area
called Broca's area associated with
speech so we represent in large
sequences of numbers as symbols that we
in tone in our own minds if you look at
a master abacus user they use the visual
cortex they're not actually representing
an abacus in terms of let of sound in
their head they're visualizing the
abacus itself right so let me show you a
beautiful video which will make this
very clear nevertheless eight years of
hard slug can produce jaw-dropping
results 12 year old Kota kozuka is top
of the class I practiced two hours on
weekdays and ten hours on the weekend I
want to become Bellagio champion I along
with the other high flyers he can now do
huge calculation so if you lingered
imaginary abacus manipulating nothing
but thin air
children like this show us that with
enough practice superfast mental
calculation is possible hi hi there mate
if you watch the documentary the
instructor says I only occasionally hit
them uh but again I just so you
understand what's going on here right is
when these kids are interviewed and
asked how do you do that this have no
idea totally unconscious I'm
manipulating an abacus I'm not adding
numbers or multiplying numbers were
dividing okay so what's happened here is
again this notion that our intelligence
fundamentally this level consists in a
shift of representation and a shunting
to a part of the brain where the problem
becomes effortless because you're
manipulating a large part of the cortex
which is extraordinarily well adapted to
visual scenes our visual system is very
powerful if you can recode hard
information in terms of inputs that the
visual system can comprehend you could
solve almost any problem and so when
people say they can think geometrically
about problems that's what they're doing
they're you're doing it the slow
symbolic way which we're not actually
very good at and they're doing it the
geometric way which were incredibly good
at so this is the closest I'll come to a
definition of intelligence in these
letters okay and it's this discovering
representations over which specialized
circuitry can infer strategic solutions
easily okay intelligence means not doing
things the hard way so we're sort of at
the end so this is a quick one so what
have I said so I've said so humans don't
seem to have fundamentally different
brains from other species so that first
part of the talk when you look at all
these scaling results there's nothing
that pops out at you which says AHA the
magical ingredient that can explain why
we are so different there isn't such a
what we might have is just more cells
okay the cells as I showed you with the
mirror neurons and the face recognition
neurons and the cell with perfect pitch
have extraordinary representational
power so and you have millions and
millions of them in your head so
multiple cells expand this
representational strategic inferential
capability right by allowing for pruning
and so if you just had one it would be a
dedicated representational cell if you
have millions and millions you can
actually dispense with many at very
little cost and when you put all of
these together right they give us this
capability which is really not at all
explored in fact the two thinkers if
you're interested in this who I think a
thought about it hardest are really
philosophers Andy Clark and Ed Hutchins
Annie Clark wrote a very nice book
called supersize your mind which is all
about externalizing cognition it's very
interesting but that's something that we
do and what I don't know how to do is go
from this multiple representational cell
to this capability there there is no
theory I don't claim to have one and i
can tell you no one else does either so
tomorrow what i'm going to show you is
the ultimate example of the outsourcing
of our intelligence right some might
claim the complete outsourcing of our
intelligence
into the extraordinary representational
image inferential power of the computer
and so the talk will be asking these
questions know how much of our
intelligence gets externalized in
silicon right will it lead to the
Eclipse of human reason right how will
we know how will we be able to test
machines and there's been a long history
interestingly in trying to build IQ
tests for computers and they're quite
amusing as you will see and what are the
implications for the future of humanity
this is a important ethical question
that we should be asking ourselves when
it gets to the point where something
else in the world might be in some sense
smarter than us if we use ourselves as
an ethical model it's alarming and thank
you goodnight hope to see tomorrow
as a question right here yes a huge
amount yeah so let me explain the
question and translate it slightly one
of the things that people would say
about cells is that they have a fixed
behavior you can't modify them right
whereas the brain can learn and that
sometimes called plasticity the let me
just give the example of a neuron your
neurons in your brain adapt constantly
to changing inputs and so in your
honesty so I don't know how much you
know about neurons maybe you know a lot
but the neurons integrate incoming
activity and send out signals in
response and neurons can maximize the
information flow from the input to the
output which can be measured using a
statistical mutual information and that
changes during the lifetime of the cell
and according to the regularities in the
data you feed it so single cells have
huge plasticity okay and so the answer
is yes
well let me well I yes well in fact I
talked about this yesterday briefly so
if you look at the congenitally blind
who are not using their visual cortex
for processing visual images they shunt
word representations and so cells that
you might think we're dedicated vision
are quite happy to do speech yes in fact
but how do you measure that in other
species see the problem I understand
what you're saying but here's the
problem we've had centuries of
anthropomorphic theories that put
consciousness at the center of the
discussion where we can't even measure
it in another human right in other words
we know ourselves internally that we are
but we can't be sure someone else's as
you know endless inc has been spilt
right what I'm trying to do is say that
doesn't look at the moment like a very
productive trajectory okay I'll let
other people do it and what I want to
answer is some slightly more modest
questions that don't necessarily bear
directly on awareness where people have
neglected the capabilities either of
their constituents or of other species
it's it's not that I don't think it's
important but there are so many people
thought about it and by defining in
those terms you're essentially ensuring
that you can never answer it and that's
my but you can't even answer it another
humans it alone other species it's
important but too many people are
working on it for me to work on it yes
I'm so you do it's right so yeah so
there's that I ain't so there are many
arguments about what it is and a Douglas
Hofstadter who wrote a wonderful book
called girdle I Shabak and recently a
book called IMA strange loop is very
interested in this notion of recursion
systems that look at themselves looking
at themselves looking at themselves
right and that which we can sort of do
what am I thinking I'm thinking I'm
thinking I'm thinking that kind of thing
like we can say it in language and we
think we can do it cognitively and that
that's the essence of consciousness
there's I don't know who I mean at the
level of a metaphor it seems intriguing
but I'm not sure in what sense it
presents itself as a logical answer
again not much progress on that in fact
we've been recently working on recursion
your nonhumans because it's a very
interesting property but I if someone
else has if someone has a way of making
that persuasive solution really
answering the awareness problem I'd like
to hear it yes
yes
yes yes so there is a if people are
interested in this the person who's done
I think the best work in this area is
Dennis Bray and Dennis Bray wrote a book
called wetware and what Bray argues is
that it's not just sells at a smart it's
proteins in cells so he's he's even more
radical than I am right and so and and
the reason he argues that is related to
the question this gentleman asked is
that there's even plasticity within the
cell that it seems and this is something
that Walter is very interested in it
seems that there are proteins can adopt
multiple different configurations
perform different functions it really
does look as if it goes very far down
the question is where does it stop no
let up yes why don't we get this one
here and now
mm-hmm
you're absolutely right that's that's
the question what I'm you're correct i
think they're very related and so for
those who didn't say yes alright so that
the the comment more like a question was
that the abacus masters ability to
manipulate equations or numbers
spatially with their fingers resembled
the ability of the kid yesterday to
manipulate the Rubik's Cube blindfold
and I think that's absolutely right and
they both illustrate this idea that
we're doing computations in a geometric
motor domain not in the domain of the
linguistic competence and that's why
they do it so well if they had to use
language which is the thing everyone
says we do do so well they couldn't do
it at all right now how is it done that
the representation is shifted it always
seems to have to be mediated by an
external object whether it's the rubik's
cube or the abacus we don't seem to be
able to do it internally and I don't
know the answer to that
yeah absolutely a musician same thing
again when athlete I i would agree do
theirs right at the back right at the
back haha so is that you sound sorry so
in both cases they were adolescent boys
yeah it's interesting yeah well there's
two possible answers to that okay and so
one is relating to this issue of
plasticity so Garrett the question was
right the observation that the
individuals able to perform these tasks
incredibly well with children there were
women to either he was interviewed yep
well but I think that was I think that's
statistically not significant that was
what we call an N of 1 if you looked in
that class there are it was coincidence
there were there were girls in that
classroom but here's maybe the thing
that's not coincidental so so the
serious answer that is one is that it's
true that children have greater
plasticity than adults so that's true
for language learning right it's true in
sport doesn't mean that adults are sort
of hardwired by any knees right and
there's a confounding factor which has
to do with obsessiveness right with
right single-minded pursuit of
excellence in a domain of absolutely no
consequence right right and I think that
might be the male characteristic
rather than right because if you think
about deductive frameworks where we
excel they tend to have that autistic
quality to them it does it strongly
relates to Bobby Fischer absolutely or
does yeah I agree there's another one
I'm sorry the lights man yeah no no so
so they are so I am a mechanist and so
if you like I could have given my entire
tour in 10 years using chemical language
the advantage of intentional or mental
istic turns is that they summarize
concisely all of those chemical
processes going on that I could have
substituted I could effortlessly have
substituted and had exactly the same
meaning so I think this is a completely
misleading belief and so
anthropomorphism is in fact useful
because it's a means of efficiently
compressing language so that you do not
have to give microscopic descriptions so
I believe if you were to ask me when we
piss you something we're doing exactly
the same thing we have a whole bunch of
chemical reactions that are simply
pursuing a chemical free energy goal
it's just that there's a language that
has a semantic valence and is efficient
that I can use to communicate to you but
I would not make a distinction at all
yes please so that is that you is that
many Charlotte yes and so I can't see
you're just a profile it from where I am
the so this is very interesting and so
take chess in it as an example right one
of the things that very good chess
players do
is that they memorize and i'll talk
about this tomorrow huge huge numbers of
plays there's something called playing
in and out of book if you play chess and
so when you start playing chess every
move is in some sense already written
down in the great book of chess right as
you hit the endgame every move is
written down in the great book of chess
and so there's an opening game and
there's an end game and they've been
getting bigger and bigger and bigger and
bigger right and it's only in the mid
game which has huge combinatorial
possibility that you're playing out of
book you're not using memory using
inference okay and we're why computers
have been so good is that they've been
in some sense shrinking that out of game
play now good mathematicians right have
incredible memory for tricks to solve
problems easily I'm not saying that's
all there is to it but so I think memory
is a critical ingredient and massively
unders and a valued ingredient in
intelligence in fact most really smart
people i know have very good memories
they pretend they don't because they
think that having a good memories
cheating but in fact having a good
memory is being smart i claim idiot yes
but you know we're fortunate now that we
can all be smart by externalizing it all
on our iPads but it did it right I mean
one of the advantages of having it
internal is we have very very rapid
access so it looks effortless but I
think it's very important yep yes please
oh dear
how would you define it I know your
plant no I think that well so here's the
cop out it could be you know calculating
without conscious access now what does
that mean okay I mean they're clearly
many things we do without being
conscious of them and so I'm not sure
that's really an answer at all I don't
have a good answer think it's a very
deep question and I don't know the
answer to it yes please no no the
problem with this is that these are all
words right so I think that so I don't
think there's a big difference in the
old days people would say animals have
instinct humans have intelligence and so
in some sense it was a lesser form and
the I think the connotation is hardwired
that not easily modified non-flexible
thing so I think that's what it can note
and I and I don't I don't really believe
in it and so we do we are if you like
born with certain biases in how we
respond to inputs okay in statistics
these would be called priors right and I
think instinct if it has any meaning is
something like the biases we have before
we learn alternative ways of reasoning I
don't like it just as a arbitrary
demarcation between human and non-human
intelligence
let me get this person yes please
yeah well I mean it's worth making a
distinction between the processing of
visual scenes and the optics okay so
known no remember though I was unleashed
I wasn't showing you visual so okay so I
was showing you the sensitivity of the
eye to touch so you can make a
homunculus for a sensory system so
remember i told you so if i were to
touch your your finger how sensitive how
much neural tissue you said i'm saying
it needs to be mapped to that kind of
sensation and what you were seeing there
was the sensitivity of the I not the
total amount of cortex dedicated to
vision do you see right yeah it's good
question I thought someone yes you did
yes right Oh got you the kidnapping of
concepts yeah
this is the worst audience in a world so
no these are sort of the questions I so
so so let me expand a little bit on it
so that the first honest remark would be
that we don't have a theory of abduction
the closest that we come to is a theory
of generalization and I talked about
this recently and that is that you spot
correspondences in the structure of
problems and you realize that the
inferential processes that you use on a
can be generalized to be and that a foot
looks can often look like a reduction so
you could save some how did you possibly
solve that it looked so totally new and
different well it wasn't because they
saw the underlying structural
equivalents okay so that that would be
one answer now in terms of improvisation
in music I really I mean I used to play
jazz as a kid you know I know what it
means i I really don't know i mean
there's a music there are musicians in
the audience i know there's a composer
in the audience who probably would give
you a better answer than I would would
anyone be willing to offer well ok so
for so it was a setup yeah yeah
right
well maybe that that essentially because
perhaps that gets to this idea that I
mentioned yesterday of composition of
representations right and so which
sounds very much like what you're saying
that there are ways of representing
problems that allow you to mesh them
together and recognizing how to
translate them into terms that allows
you to do it is the key that's an
interesting let me just take I know that
derouin I'll get let me get one more and
let me get two more your Rubin you're
not allowed to say anything difficult or
harsh scientists are mainly interested
in intelligence but psychiatrists
therapists schoolteachers deal with
stupidity a lot it would be interesting
if brain scientists and theorists could
figure out why there's so much stupidity
I mean the natural selection would lead
to intelligence well doesn't it we would
survive and not destroy the world but
stupidity see stronger why is that
I don't know what I don't know I don't
think we see I I don't agree with you
and I don't think the problem is
stupidity it might be ethics so you
could have extremely mean just think
about scientists who commit war crimes
this is not the absence of intelligence
it's the absence of judgment now you
might say okay fair enough I'm being
inconsistent it's the absence of one
form of intelligence right and so I want
to make that clear that I don't think
that ethics is synonymous with deductive
power okay now the other point though
stupidity and society and what makes
individuals stupid I don't think it has
anything to do with darkness and more
natural selection I think that we're all
basically I know we are all equivalent
genetically forget you but I do think it
has this is where pedagogy becomes a
critical I think that it has to do with
preferential access to thoughtful people
who can identify representations that
work for you right I mean if everyone
has to be spoon-fed the same
representation it's not going to work
and so I don't think if anything to do
with genetics or anything to do with
evolution because we've reached the
point where genetically we are
effectively as a morphic at least it
with respect to the genes that
contribute to the development of the
nervous system there are differences in
disease susceptibility but not as far as
we know in terms of cognition
oh right in the back okay
no but you're giving an example of a
regimen of very strict training which in
your case had to do with various frugal
considerations which of the analog of B
of this kid being trained by his you
know sense I'd be beaten senseless if he
didn't work effectively on his abacus so
and you know and again right you did
internalized it make it almost a
subconscious process which i think is
one of the hallmarks of reasoning
carefully so I would agree but before
you will go and remind you that tomorrow
is so much more exciting and so I hope
to see you again
you